you look amazing you know it's so great
because I nothing accents an outfit like
two Olympic medals no yeah they're
actually really heavy yeah check it out
yeah I'd love to check it out there's
chocolate inside I'll be disappointed
and delighted yes medals nice really
would not dishonor it by wearing it but
that is that is quite heavy that is
fantastic that's absolutely beautiful
yeah okay thank you no I'm so honored
early late yeah it's so it's such an
amazing first of all how does it feel to
be back in United States after being how
long were you in South Korea just shy of
a month a month okay longest I've been
anywhere in a long time yeah
and so how does it feel what were you
jonesing for when you got back here well
I wanted to run to the ocean and jump in
and then I got here I'm like whoa it's
really cold yeah yeah it's been cold
here in Los Angeles it's can't believe
we keep the window open it's been it's
been in like the 40s and 30s and people
in the East Coast laughs and I'm from
the East Coast we know real cold but yet
people out here are freaking out because
they can't see their breath you know
feels good though it's usually so warm
I'm like I kind of like kinda like it
coolness yeah all right way warmer than
Korea yeah breathing over there let's
talk about this a couple of things first
of all you are known in a sport where
people athletes can be fairly relaxed
you are known to be particularly Zen and
chill to the point where it annoys your
competitors would you say that that's
fair um I mean it takes a lot of
practice I feel like we can all be chill
and we all have different stresses to
deal with no not all of us can be chill
I can never be chill and I never will be
chill but it's nice that you can be
chill bit bit but sometimes you're so
calm before a big event that it's a
little unnerving to people around you
isn't that true I believe you do it I
was I couldn't believe how relaxed I was
I'm like I'm down these gel lives are
good yeah kind of what I need yeah yeah
so what were you I mean you you had a
really good night's sleep the night
before your events surprisingly I always
think that I won't be able to sleep and
then the night before I slept good I
woke up we had like an early morning
which is always difficult
yeah and went to the athlete lounge and
yeah everyone was a little tense and I
was like jamming my beats by dre I
brought my speaker because the Olympics
is a little stiff like they don't have
music everywhere I'm right music is key
right so I come in with my music
drinking my tea making a coffee and then
all of a sudden everyone's leaving like
rushing out to the course and I like
still had to do up my boots right and
then of course like with the weather and
everything it was a little delayed but
yeah let's talk about that because the
weather was people don't realize until
they were watching this Olympics the
wind the high winds for your events
meant that sometimes you were delayed
for a long time and you had to sometimes
change your plan for what you were going
to do because some of the you know some
of the moves that you wanted to pull off
you can't pull off if the winds too high
isn't that right factly like even the
run I did and one Gold width
it wasn't my most difficult run and
unfortunately all the women are writing
so good right now and we saw that later
in the Olympics with big air but it's
kind of how it goes like sometimes your
most of the time you're dealing with
winter elements you know there's when
there's snow there's all kinds of
conditions and one thing I've practiced
forever it's just like embracing what is
and going with the flow and it's not
always easy like I had a terrible
practice I was freaking out so with my
boyfriend I'm like I don't know what to
do like I was shaking and like we had 40
minutes which is not a lot of time it's
like couple of laps and that's life
though weather you know we got to deal
with whatever comes I'm actually
relieved that you're admitting to some
anxiety you know because it is
it's making me feel like okay good
because if you're a chill all the time
about everything I'd think that you were
a god you know no I'm only human
you